this is strange this is so weird back in
2020 when Co lockdown was happening I
was like all right well there are no
movies so I'll pull from the 90s and
review movies I have not talked about or
reviewed on my channel yet dark city was
one of those movies which is to say for
the past three years I have believed
I've had a dark city review out there in
the world on my channel and I guess I
just haven't I know it probably sounds
like I'm making jokes because dark city
I'm not I swear
I don't understand this anyhow let's
review dark city for the first time in
my Channel's history
[Music]
apparently also this is going to be a
spoiler free review I don't care how
many years ago this movie came out it
could be a hundred years still should do
a spoiler-free review cuz that's the
point here to Intrigue some people who
haven't seen dark city into seeing dark
city so you can have that magical
experience so dark city came out in 1998
directed by Alex prus the director of
The Crow which was man in the 9s he was
in the zone with the one two punch of a
crow in dark city it stars Rufus Su as
Mr Murdoch who wakes up with a case of
Amnesia does not know who he is he's
trying to find out who he is a detective
played by William Herz also looking for
him cuz he's like I think he might be a
serial killer also these really pale
creepy guys and long coats who float are
also looking for him it's an amazing
beautiful looking and compelling Noir
sci-fi and if you're about to bounce cuz
I have not kept your attention on this
one please take this one with you watch
the director's cut not the theatrical
cut because an entire audience of people
who saw the theatrical cut got the movie
ruined for them there is a key for
voiceover at the very beginning of the
theatrical cut of dark city spoiling the
who what when where why of the entire
film tainting the experience of this
mystery because any clues you're seeing
you're now seeing through spoiler
goggles that you're not supposed to have
you're not supposed to have this
information until the last Act that was
a studio call the studio said well you
need that because audiences are too dumb
to stay engaged and follow this movie
because well your movie trailer was
[__] perfect visuals imagery Intrigue
that awesome song that I believe came
from the trailer of dark city it's also
on the DVD menu of Brotherhood of the
wolf it's that song it's a perfect
trailer song It's a movie that gets
better every time I watch it it truly is
timeless but it's Timeless in the sense
that it is a deconstruction of and
asking the question of what is
consciousness what are we that's not
something you think about less as you
get older you only think about it more
which means you only relate to dark city
more this was the first movie I can
remember seeing Rufus Su in he's great
and perfect for
Murdoch I don't even want to spoil his
first name it's no big deal but still at
a points like Jay Murdoch what does that
mean and you're supposed to experience
that he's perfect in this film as the
everyday man maybe he's a serial killer
maybe he's a good guy he has the look of
both he has an intensity in his eyes
I've always loved it dark city is the
top tier perfect casting when it comes
to Rufus Su the one that shocked me was
key for Southerland in the trailer he
has the most epic turnaround because
something got your attention scene I was
like oh Kefir is going to be such a
[__] badass look at him he's he's not
that kind of guy he's a bit of a
tortured and tormented Soul you could
have a prequel film revolving all around
his
character I really hope they don't do
that now that I threw that out there
into the universe don't do that
Hollywood don't [__] up dark city but
Rufus Jennifer Connelly kefir souland
William Hurt they're all great in the
film to no one's surprised and want to
give some love to Richard O'Brien as Mr
Hand among the mystery men in dark city
he's the main one leading the pursuit
for Rufus su's character and he's
fantastic a complete scene stealer also
given the premise of the film very
complex now from the visuals in the
trailer you can tell there's more going
on here than just is this guy a serial
killer or not and you'd be 100% correct
in that assessment but again it's more
fun for you to experience if you haven't
already than to hear my ass talk about
it but what I love is it stays in the
zone I would describe dark city as a
Noir sci-fi the real MVP is the camera
work in tone the cinematography creating
this world in dark city it is God here
that hybrid aesthetic of different
decades coming together going Splat
almost feels like Burton's Batman if it
took place all at night and felt more
claustrophobic dark city might very well
be the film that taught Hollywood hey if
you do CGI in dark scenes or at night it
hides it I mean it's 1998 CGI so it's
still noticeable the very end of the
movie has more of it but the road
getting there like when there CGI scene
sprinkled into the film and the city's
changing dude it's really cool looking
it was at the time we all have trained
eyes at this point to notice CGI but the
high concept it's dealing with that's
what makes it land still I will say
there is a point in the last act where
it's a lot more CGI and it's all
happening a lot faster just in terms of
tone and visuals it just kind of it it
always felt out of place it feels like
the antithesis of the road leading to it
it doesn't ruin the experience of dark
city it's just it's worth mentioning
because it is a review after all again
the end dark city is an absolute sci-fi
classic of the 9s dark city is just
engaging from the very beginning the
moment he wakes up your hook him not
knowing any more or less than the
audience and vice versa it's the perfect
setup for a film in which you're
discovering the answers together also in
the way it's executed it's a great
rewatch now knowing the answers going
back through the film no idea why some
suit somewhere would make the call yeah
but let's ruin all of that with a voice
over at the
beginning boom it's an intriguing
engaging beautiful sci-fi Noir that you
will only relate to more the older you
get and dark city is awesome
[Music]
tacular all right so dark city have you
seen it what did you think about it it
was a sci-fi film that doesn't get a lot
of chatter but should get more chatter
because it's that great whatever it is
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more right here to see
[Music]
more